speaking of being thankful we begin this
hour with a simple question
what are you grateful for it's a
question that's being answered daily in
journals placed across the country from
coffee shops to classrooms anyone can
write or read the entries it all comes
from the mind of a man who's on his own
journey to find gratitude through his
work he's made it possible for many
others to do the same lead national
correspondent david bagnell met the
young man inspired by his mother to find
passion and purpose in the tiniest
moments of life
in coffee shops around the country
you might want to look out for a little
book titled today i am grateful for
it's there so that people in search of a
latte can also search their souls
and write a few words about what they
are grateful for
astoria coffee in new york city was the
first place the book showed up it's so
simple it's just a few minutes every day
teddy droseros who for 10 years has
written down what he is grateful for
every day thankful for the amazing
dinner i had with my brother put the
book in the coffee shop with the
permission of the owner so a story you
drop it off and then do you keep going
back to the coffee shop every day uh
yeah i check up on it and write myself
and what was it like seeing people
sitting there writing in it that's
always an awesome experience like
because people would just take it and
bring it to their seat and just and just
read through it so explain to me what
the gratitude journal was gonna be i was
just like oh this is just a tool that i
can leave around everywhere to inspire
people to practice gratitude
[Music]
it didn't take long before the book
filled up and so another one was left
there i'm thankful for my pup my health
friends and fam i'm grateful for living
room dance parties and non-sexual
intimacy
i love it
i love it
and at bird rock coffee in san diego
california he put out more books after
he moved there
so then how many coffee shops did you
end up giving books to around the
country i actually don't know my friends
would help me out you know when they
were traveling they would get books out
there and then i started getting random
emails from strangers saying hey i saw
this in this coffee shop can we bring it
to my neighborhood he calls his project
grateful peoples and a lot of that
gratitude comes right back to him after
the books are all filled up how many of
them came back at least 100 i'd say so
when you got your first book back and
you went through it
how was that i noticed that when i would
feel down i would go pick up one of the
filled up books i collected it would
like instant make me feel better
teddy droseros by his own admission was
not always a grateful person and thinks
about that when he comes here where he
watched his mother's ashes flow into the
pacific ocean what did she have she was
diagnosed with multiple sclerosis when i
was a baby but it eventually passed from
cancer
his mother's illness robbed him of a
normal childhood and it left him bitter
he says
my experience with her and her sickness
you know ms
impacts the brain and changes behavior
and personality and it was difficult it
was kind of hard to be grateful for it
at the time but and the thing with why i
became so passionate about gratitude and
started grateful people is because the
more time i took to write in this
journal
i realized that everything i was
experiencing with my mom was
seriously my biggest blessing i'll
probably ever have do you have your
first entry uh yeah
february 29 2012
i'm thankful i was born healthy into a
great family with all limbs and able to
do everything i was able to as a child
playing all those sports growing up was
a blessing if you need a fresh journal
now schools have teamed up with grateful
peoples because teddy joseos has
distributed 20 000 books to school
children i'm grateful for my father i am
grateful for how education changed how i
spoke and how i wrote i'm grateful for
my little brother doing good in school
it turns out that gratitude can foster
more gratitude and people actually want
to read about it so you ended up writing
a book and the book was written with the
entries of all kinds of people yeah it
was just like a like a collection of
gratitude thoughts and what'd you call
the book today i'm grateful for and how
many entries about a thousand did you
read every one of those in the book so i
collected 75 000 entries and i read
through every single one which was a
blessing because it was just like 75 000
bits of perspective
somewhere in those 75 000 injuries was
one that said deanna and today remains
part of the legacy of deanna mandelo a
dancer who died too young at 28 years
old in a car crash
[Music]
when someone passes you kind of you want
to collect everything in every memory
and everything that they touched and
wrote jen freeman a fellow dancer was
among the people who knew that a
gratitude book at that astoria coffee
shop
held a link to her friend diana so i
went to the coffee shop and i asked who
was responsible for these journals and
they put me in touch with teddy did
deanna seem to you to be a person of
gratitude
yes and that is what is really
beautiful and sort of serendipitous
about
this whole connection coming together
hearing about deanna was sort of the
catalyst for him to
actually embark on this journey of
creating this book makes so much sense
to me because that was the way she lived
her life like she
always was expressing her gratitude and
teddy's own mother just before she died
wrote on july 11 2019
she wrote i'm grateful to be alive just
knowing where my mom was when she wrote
that the fact that she was able to just
think and feel that way is special to me
and
that's why i love this journal and i'll
have it with me forever i got a piece of
my mom here
it's been five years since teddy
droseros first left that gratitude book
at that new york city coffee shop
he's still writing in him
a new one these days
and more often than not
about his mother
the more you lose the more i gain as
your illness took away the simple things
it made me realize how lucky i am to
have them
i'm not sure i'd understand how lucky i
am to tie my own shoes if i didn't have
to tie yours when you couldn't do it
anymore but gratitude taught me it only
makes sense to love something i can't
change it's the inspiration behind
everything i do
i just had a big aha moment
gratitude taught me to love something i
cannot change yeah
that that's what gratitude does it just
it allows you to shift your perspective
of what already is like i can't change
that my mom was sick but i can look at
it as a blessing or i can look at it as
something dark
but my relationship with her is the best
it's ever been
it really is
even though she's long gone it continues
yeah for sure i'm more connected to her
now than i ever was
boy david teddy thank you a lot of
lessons there i'm so touched by him
despite his pain and his bitterness that
he said he still finds reasons to be
grateful i think that's a lesson for all
of us it's the smallest things that make
a difference in your life stuff you take
for granted that you don't focus on you
know i said to him what did you take
away from
reading all 75 000 entries in those
books and he said one thing that people
who go through pain almost always emerge
with some degree of gratitude
yeah you know they always say you have
to go through pain to experience joy but
sometimes when you're going through the
pain it's very very difficult to
understand how joy can come out or how
you can come out on the other side you
know who goes through pain in this world
every single person
you're so right tony i'm reading
whatever nobody's immune and reading
what others are thankful for allows you
to have like he said perspective on your
own world yeah yeah david you did it
once again thank you so much